leider müssen wir in den letzten jahren
immer mehr antijüdische demonstrationen
in deutschlands großstädten sehen wir
haben in deutschland zu recht sehr stark
den fokus darauf dass der
rechtsextremismus eine große gefahr
darstellt und das bis leider sehr
starken rechtsextrem
hass auf juden gibt aber was häufig
vergessen wird bei der ganzen debatte
ist dass mancher islamismus leider nach
deutschland importiert wird der
judenhass der immer mehr um sich greift
gerade in deutschlands großstädten der
kommt teilweise aus arabischen staaten
nach deutschland wir haben gesehen in
den vergangenen jahren kommen menschen
nach deutschland die das judentum an
sich ablehnen und das können wir als
bundesrepublik deutschland nicht
akzeptieren wir brauchen eine ehrliche
debatte die in alle richtungen schaut
die sich den die den rechtsextremismus
beleuchtet die den linksextremismus
beleuchtet die sich aber auch mit
islamismus auseinandersetzt und den
fokus darauf legt dass aus all diesen
extremistischen er wurzeln judenhass
resultiert und deswegen mein plädoyer
wir brauchen in deutschland eine
ehrliche debatte darüber und wir
brauchen harte konsequenzen damit der
hass auf unsere jüdischen mitbürger ein
ende hat und damit wir die bilder die
wir gerade auch in den vergangenen tagen
in deutschlands großstädten sehen
mussten endlich ein ende haben + ich
finde es toll dass sie das so
aussprechen denn es ist ja so dass wir
in deutschland eigentlich eine
meinungsklima ist wo man nach wie vor
den eindruck hat es kostet ein
eigentlich überwindung und es braucht
mut diese dinge so anzusprechen obwohl
das ja phänomene sind die ja jedes kind
eigentlich sehen kann man sich ja diese
aggressiven männer man hört was die
rufen man weiß woher sie kommen man weiß
warum sie bei uns im land sind man weiß
was wir probleme wir haben mit einer
ungeregelten zuwanderung das sind alles
themen die man dringend in angriff
nehmen musste und dennoch sind wir nach
wie vor eigentlich eine situation
die flüchtlingskrise begann jahr 2015
das ist jetzt schon sieben jahre her
ungefähr dass wir eigentlich nicht die
richtigen konsequenzen gezogen habe also
wenn frau feser unsere innenministerin
immer noch sagt es gibt rechten
antisemitismus und antisemitismus egal
von wem so in dem sinne äußert sie sich
ja oft und nicht klar benennt als
innenministerin es gibt linksextremismus
es gibt diesen islamismus es gibt
islamistischen antisemitismus einfach
das problem benennen da sind wir noch
nicht auf der ebene der lösung der sind
wir auf der ebene des benehmens wenn sie
das nicht tut dann zeigt das dass wir
ein ganz großes problem haben und auch
einer lösung nicht näher kommen bloß das
ist uns doch allen klar was passieren
würde wenn sie das was sie da gerade
eben erzählt haben in einem anderen
forum erzählen
vielleicht mancher redaktionskonferenz
manches mediums sie hören den
rassismus-vorwurf das ist das was
passiert natürlich ist dieser vorwurf
unsinnig aber warum wird er erhoben er
wird erhoben weil es eine immer
mächtiger werdende
ideologie gibt in deutschland einen
universitäten in der gesellschaft auch
in manchen parteien die besagt alle
weißen sind rassisten und alle menschen
die eine andere hautfarbe haben sind
rassismus opfer zu dem rassismus opfern
die das qua geburt sind nicht durch
irgendeine qua geburt gehören auch leute
aus arabischen ländern zu den weißen
werden auf die juden gerechnet es gibt
da unterschiedliche schattierungen
das heißt wir haben es ich will so hart
sagen wir haben es mit der art neuem
rassismus zu tun der menschen nach
hautfarben sortiert und der
instrumentalen instrumentalisiert wird
um den rassismus über den sie zu recht
gesprochen haben nämlich dem gegen
jüdische menschen in diesem land zu
verschleiern das ist ein großes problem
und gegen diese ideologie muss man
aufstehen finde ich wenn man in der lage
sein möchte auch noch in zukunft zu
sagen was ist herr martenstein das was
sie da gerade ansprechend ist ja diese
sogenannte kritische theorie die
compostela ich halte das wie gesagt ich
wollte nicht zu computer eine so er so
für eine eigentlich progressiv gewandete
apartheids lehrer das ist letztlich dass
so etwas sich in unserer gesellschaft
wieder verbreitet das ist tatsächlich
eine gefährliche ideologie was mich
entsetzt hat ist ich habe diese
ideologie kürzlich postuliert verbreitet
gesehen auf einer seite des
bundesfamilienministeriums so weit ist
es gekommen das ist schlimm aber es
stellt sich dem ja offensichtlich auch
kaum jemanden gegen weil die menschen
angst haben sie werden dann als
rassisten irgendwie beschimpft oder so
es müssen weil er ja noch mal sozusagen
der andere debatte ist also ich habe
mich dann aber wenn wir lang genau also
ich hab das auch in den vergangenen
jahren immer wieder gemacht aber was ich
auch gemerkt habe ist bei den debatten
wenn man diese bilder sieht davon
großdemonstration gegen das judentum wir
haben einmal kurz tag
demonstration in anführungszeichen kurz
tag gegen jüdische mitbürger das ist
teilweise bilder die folgt bei sind
gerade auch mit blick auf die geschichte
unseres landes und wir haben ein
erkenntnisproblem in teilen der politik
gerade bei spd und grünen weil spd und
grüne häufig sagen na ja das kommt nur
von rechts oder rechtsaußen da gibt es
in der tat auch schlimmen antisemitismus
aber es gibt eben auch importierten
antisemitismus und darüber müssen wir
auch eine ehrliche debatte führen denn
migrationspolitik wird in deutschland
auf dauer nur erfolgreich sein wenn sie
klar nach regeln verläuft und wenn wir
nicht nur sagen ihr habt auch gewisse
rechte wenn ihr nach deutschland kommt
sondern ihr habt auch pflichten und wir
haben als gesellschaft eine erwartung an
all diejenigen die hier zu entziehen und
wer das judentum ablehnt und das
judentum zerstören will der hat in
deutschland nichts zu suchen schade dass
frau merkel das nicht gehört hat im jahr
2015 was sie gerade gesagt haben
ja das ist und nokia haben sie ist 2015
sogar gesagt aber es wurde trotzdem
nicht gehört frau raffelhüschen wie
offen wird in der ampel auch genau über
dieses thema gesprochen
haben sie den eindruck dass sie so ein
thema auch wie wir es jetzt hier
diskutieren ebenfalls mit kollegen und
kollegen der grünen und der spd genau so
dass goutieren könnten ohne dass man
ihnen gleich das was hartenstein auch
sagte vorwirft sie sind aber doch
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen sehr
rassistisch unterwegs also das thema ist
so noch nicht gefallen wir haben jetzt
haushaltsverhandlungen und ich hatte
jetzt gerade ein berichterstatter
gespräche mit dem familienministerium
und das sind auch posten für also gelder
für anti
antisemitismus programme und wenn man
dann fragt ja was sind das für projekte
wie teilt sich das auf also
linksextremismus rechtsextremismus und
und dann es ist so nicht aufgelistet man
muss das dann einfordern und wir gucken
uns das ganz genau an wie das verhältnis
ist weil wie sie schon sagen also da
muss auch was getan muss die ampel
aufstocken brauchen braucht deutschland
muss deutschland muss die
bundesregierung mehr in projekte stecken
mehr geld in projekte stecken die sich
speziell um das thema
islamistische antisemit sei wenn es nach
mir ginge ich werde dafür dass wir
setzen sich in haushaltsverhandlungen
wir gucken uns jetzt erst mal an wie
sind die verhältnisse wie viel geld
fließt wo hin und dann werden wir also
ich werde mich darum hat das ist ein
ausgleich geschaffen hat dass die große
koalition bisher nicht gemacht dann in
der großen koalition das muss man
wirklich sagen ist auf initiative der
cdu sehr vielen die sicherheitsorgane
investiert worden also die mittel sind
deutlich erhöht worden kann man sich
klar anschauen das ist aus meiner sicht
auch gar nicht das hauptproblem sondern
das hauptproblem ist ein
erkenntnisproblem das nehme ich immer
nur gesagt wird na ja das kommt vor
allem von rechtsaußen der antisemitismus
das ist richtig und daher wir müssen
gegen jeglichen antisemitismus von
rechtsaußen als gesellschaft alles tun
aber der importierte
islamismus der importierte
antisemitismus der spielt häufig nicht
die rolle und deswegen muss erstmal
diese erkenntnis da sein und dann kann
man auch relativ einfach politische
maßnahmen ableiten deswegen ja auch
dieses motto je dass es endlich mit auf
die agenda in deutschland kommt aber
einfluss politischer maßnahmen also ein
aggressiver junger mann nicht deutscher
staatsbürger mit im zuge der migrations
krise gekommen der juden auf der straße
angreift solche szenen gab es ja schon
in berlin in vergangenen jahren was muss
noch passieren musste außer landes
gebracht also ich bin ich bin dafür dass
also jeder der solche taten verübt er
muss nach möglichkeit sofort abgeschoben
werden oder er muss die konsequenzen des
rechtsstaates mit aller härte spüren